every day's wine prince loved that song
he jumped up on stage with you and
performed it prince wants to share that
microphone with you these men go
absolutely berserk for you they do
because i'm hot i mean you are hot even
it's fixy i'm hot right you are hot it's
[ __ ] crazy like i when i watch you
how am i not married how was that
you don't i'm too hot oh that's right
i'm too hot that's what it is you know
why i limit myself
how is it that there isn't a man strong
enough to be your man
how is it
i don't know i mean honestly i even
scratch my head and go
how did i get here without getting
married
um well you almost did i almost did
three times i was engaged three times
howard three times the first time you
were in a cover band
called cashmere
and it wasn't a led zeppelin cover band
it was a religious ban i'm gonna harden
my heart no it was a cover band that was
like pop hits and the guy in the band
you fall in love with him
and he says to you i want to marry you
but i can't marry you unless you sing
for the lord and you packed your bags
and you went off to la
i did this guy do you have any contact
with this guy after i had breast cancer
i got a nice note from him so you know
everybody eventually grows up
figures out
who they are i have a lot of
i give people a lot of leeway if they
evolved and you started to become you
know a superstar is there some sort of
um
drive in you that says you know what he
gave up on me he wasn't strong enough to
be my man no i go thank god thank you
god thank you i didn't get married i
mean honestly three times i'm like thank
you
i mean i got breast cancer at the end of
one relationship and it was horrible but
when i came through it i was like you
know what i would still be in that
relationship had i not gotten breast
cancer so
in some weird way i'm grateful and you
think you're going to be like oh you
know
f that guy or whatever but by the time
you get to that point you've moved on
and you don't really care anymore that's
right after you broke up with lance
armstrong six days later you got your
breast cancer diagnosis i did
like you were maybe gonna get married
but he proposes after his whole
controversy happens with whether he took
drugs or not all that and it was a
disappointment again with a guy like
don't propose to me when you're at your
lowest moment yeah that's happened twice
i'm always like don't wait until the
relationship's over to ask me to get
married because you don't want me to go